looking for the perfect way to make your
family movie night a little bit more
magical
i'm britt warren founder and ceo of
britain co and i've teamed up with dq to
welcome you to fandango's family movie
night
today we're going to be showing you how
to make these fancy paper crowns perfect
for the little superhero inside your
house
to get started let's collect your
materials first you'll need paper
i chose cardstock paper and metallic
paper
a stapler scissors and you can choose to
have kids scissors
and adult scissors if your little one's
going to help you a pen for tracing
some stick glue and of course some
glitter glue
for that extra flare for your first step
you're just going to trace a basic
outline for the front of your crown
and then when you're done cut it out
great now you'll notice i have this
extra strip that i've cut out because
this will actually serve as the band
you're going to want to make sure
that you measure it around your kid's
head to make sure it fits
next you're going to use your colorful
paper and your metallic paper to cut out
shapes for your crown you can see i've
cut out stars a lightning bolt
it even made this cute little earth
shape now it's time to finally assemble
your crown so we're just going to glue
on
all those different shapes you cut out
you can see i added the star i added
some squiggles
lastly for the final flare i'm just
going to add a little bit of glitter
glue
to add some sparkle
okay once you're done gluing and
painting your crown
the final step is just to attach the
band to do this you're just going to
take your stapler
and your band wrap them together
do one staple right in the middle
and of course complete the loop
is it just me or does wearing a crown
make you feel way more confident
now all you need is an oreo fudge
brownie blizzard treat from dq to make
this
a totally winning scene thanks for
watching and be sure to check out
fandango now for more fun family films
see you next time